[Music]
what's your address
chapel road
about a house store apartment that's the
house
chapel road in watsonville
okay what's going on there
uh my brother just assaulted me and i
saw here from work and
i noticed that my bike was missing and
he pretty much he took it he was the
last person that took it so he sold it
to somebody
and
i confronted him about it and i was
telling him where's my bike i wanted
someone to go get it and he just you
know he pretty much laid hands on me
so what did he do to lay hands on you he
punched me he punched me in the head
okay do you need any medical attention
um no i'll be all right
he's still there
yeah he's still here
and i'm pretty sure he has a warrant too
okay what's his name
his name's antonio
and his last name
with a z okay yeah
one second
do you know his date of birth
okay are you drinking or on drugs
yeah he's drinking
um no drugs
i'm pretty sure he's on drugs too
is he white black hispanic asian
hispanic
what's he wearing today
he's wearing a green checkered shirt and
some blue jeans
a white
shirt i'm sorry
um does he know you're calling
no he's outside right now
he probably needs her you know
what is he doing out there
he's just drinking a beer
okay
it's like a sprite yard or backyard
again in the front
and what is your name
my name
same last
yeah
okay
and your phone number is
yeah
is it just the two of you that are there
uh no my mom's my mom was here she was
trying to get in the middle and he
pushed her too so
okay where's she at now
see we're right here inside the house
okay what's her name
same last
yeah
okay
so you and her inside and your brother's
outside
yeah
okay
do you have access to a vehicle where he
would leave in
uh no he doesn't have accidents
no he doesn't
okay he has a bike so
a bicycle
yeah
okay you never found yours that's
missing no
okay no he took anything i'm pretty sure
he told it
you know
just stay separated from him until they
get there and call us back if anything
changes okay
okay thank you you're welcome bye
everyone is cooper what are you
reporting
hello hi how can i help you
i we had called earlier because uh from
my brother and
when you guys came here he didn't um
yeah they didn't catch him because he
had left but he's back
okay what's the address
okay i'm sorry so what was he after one
more time
anybody this time around or is he where
is he doing now no but he's trying to
get in the house and no longer
okay uh what's the brother's name
antonio antonio last name
is it peter
and then
where is he right now
he's ran from the house
okay is he intoxicated maybe on drugs
it looks like he's about to leave right
now he's coming putting her in his like
yeah he's getting rid of me
okay gotcha and you guys have all the
doors locked right
tell me which way he goes when he starts
riding off okay i don't want you to
sleep
oh okay yeah
i am sorry about that man which way is
he going my headset
uh he's leonardo he's going towards
7-eleven
george uh uh what is it um
what is that called
not airport it's um
okay perfect just stay in the house and
i'll have him come contact you guys
there what's your name
he's
already hitting the corner so i'm i
don't know if you want to excuse me yeah
but just yeah just go ahead and wave the
address i'll have my guy swing back
around to talk to you guys okay and did
he threaten anybody
or did he just have it in his hand no
no he was just trying to get in the
house
gotcha okay the officers have been on
the way since you called men right
[Applause]
come here
keep your hands up
keep your hands up keep your hands up
stop stop right there
get on the ground on the ground on your
stomach
on your stomach on your stomach
[Applause]
get on the ground right now you're going
to get taste
get on the ground
get on the ground
why are you making it harder than it has
to be dude get on the ground
flat down on your stomach flat down on
your stomach
get on your stomach
dude get on your stomach
dude get on your stomach
holy
on your stomach get on your stomach
get on your stomach
on your stomach
on your stomach
stop
all right
[Music]
stay right there
keep an eye on them
[Applause]
slippery
[Applause]